Lucy leppy who was found guilty of
murdering seven babies on a neonatal
unit by deliberately injecting them with
Air Force feeding others milk and
poisoning two of the infants with
insulin everyone at work blows off steam
in different ways why are we piling on
her she's got it all she's a babe she's
got blonde hair bab's Ville she was just
getting started she was early on in her
criminal career there was like a long
time between when they first suspected
the nurse of doing some misdeeds and
bringing the police involved cuz when
you get the police involved they can do
some uh it's canel cancel culture no
they found a note in Lucy's apartment
she just says I'm an awful person I'm
evil hate every post in my house looks
like this I killed them on purpose cuz
I'm not good enough it's funny she has
to start writing a little writing
smaller cuz she's running out of posted
note get a bigger piece of paper you
dumb